my life matters i don't need your  privilege to tell me or to justify who i  am in america this is my country and i  don't have to have you name it  is better than mine but you are  supporting an organization that does not  like black men and as a black woman i  can tell you how important black men are  to the black family without them we are  nothing love her she gets it right down  to the bottom  so this this white liberal kid  is talking about how great black lives  matter is she goes you don't know  anything about black lives or black  lives matter for that matter black lives  matter is terrible for black people  black lives matter is terrible for a  great many reasons but in particular  because it wants to subvert the family  it's very bad for black men and  if you're supporting the destruction of  the black family then you're as bad as  anybody